how to be creative
so i'm at the airport i just arrived and
i saw a question
while i was at tim hortons picking up my
ice cap
and uh it was a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
michelle who wrote in to ask about what
do you do when you're stuck how do you
be creative when you're stuck how do you
get that idea
and i thought you know i gotta make this
quick video before we hire before i get
into the airport
uh creative you come from two things
okay it'll come from
exposure to new ideas and it'll come
from freedom
and i'll go over both quickly exposure
to new ideas if you're not getting any
creative
new ideas right now chances are your
life is boring your life is too boring
your routine is too boring your schedule
is too boring you're doing the same
thing
every day and it's boring and you're
probably not really happy right now
creativity comes from variety right you
got to expose yourself to new ideas for
new opportunities you gotta
do things that stretch your comfort zone
a little bit and from there
you'll get creative ideas now i'm at the
airport right now traveling
is a great place to get creative ideas
every time you travel
you get new creative ideas to bring back
into your business into your life
it opens your eyes it refreshes your
thinking and you know you may not be
able to afford to go traveling right now
so
you know that's fine but find other ways
to change up your schedule
to be able to go out and do things that
are different and new and fun and expose
yourself
to ideas and people that bring out a
different side in you
you know i get a ton of credit creative
ideas because i
am surrounded by people
who who bring out different sides of me
who expose me to new ideas
and i've created a schedule where i've
factored that in where i'm doing
different things all the time so today
i'm at the airport
uh you know on the weekend as an example
i went to two trade shows
okay i like going to trade shows uh just
to see what's going on what people are
up to the different businesses that are
there
the first one was an rv trade show where
people were selling
campers and trailers and uh and buses
and everything you need to go camping
and
my wife and i go camping a couple times
a year and i thought hey we should we
should check that out
maybe get a motorhome uh whatever just
to educate ourselves
so that was on the saturday then on the
sunday at the same building
in uh just next door was the sexapalooza
show
and so we went to that and uh
totally different crowd totally
different vibe and it's probably safe to
say that we were
one of the only couple if not the only
couple to go to both
shows on the same weekend right the you
think the audience going to a rv trailer
show is gonna be different
than the ones going to the sexapalooza
show but we were there both
and that you know being exposed to those
kinds of ideas and
and different uh different culture and
different
different subgroups makes you more
creative even if
even if you're not like i'm not a
hardcore camper i'm not a hardcore
uh you know uh well i'm not an anything
kind of s
m guy but anyway maybe that's too
detailed i'm a pretty normal
meat and potatoes guy there but getting
in the details on the
evan carmichael channel but it doesn't
matter because those
being around different people and
different ideas will make you more
creative so
your schedule is probably too boring
your life is probably too boring right
now and you got to break out and do
something different
okay so that's the first one new ideas
and experiences the second is freedom
you got to give yourself the time to go
out
and do all these things creativity can't
be forced
you know if you have a goal to say hey i
want to get better at piano i want to
get better with email
marketing the more you practice the more
you focus the better you're going to get
at it right the more i practice my
scales and piano the better i'm going to
get at it with creativity
it's almost the opposite right you can't
say i'm going to be creative right now
right you that's why brainstorming
meetings often don't work very well
because you're
forcing people to be creative on the
spot where creativity will often come
from
taking walks uh sitting on the toilet
being in the shower right that's where
you get all your creative ideas because
you have a little bit of time where your
brain has
freedom where so many people are so over
scheduled
over committed that you're so worried
and stressed out about what you have to
do
that you have zero time to focus on
things that could help you grow new
creative ideas
so you have to open up chunks of your
time you have to be willing to go out
and
and and shower more go for walks
give yourself more time stop scheduling
so much stuff in there
okay that's how you get creative ideas
if you do those two things if you
consistently expose yourself
to people and ideas that are different
from you and you give yourself the
freedom to be able to explore
i guarantee you you're gonna come up
with a ton of creative ideas
and then your next question is going to
be how do i execute
but we'll worry about that when we get
there anyway i'm going to get in
thank you guys for watching believe you
guys like this video you want to see
more like it
subscribe to the channel uh i want to
know how you get
creative i want to know where your best
creative ideas come from leave a comment
below i'd love to hear from you
thank you guys i'll see you soon
evan your newsletters have taught me not
to quit
i look forward to them every week they
have changed my life
thank you
you